le cœur de Kiev la capitale ukrainienne
a encore une fois été visé tô ce matin
par des missiles russes plusieurs
bâtiments résidentiel et entrepôt ont
été touché alors que des milliers de
personnes s'apprêtaient à se rendre au
travail comme ici dans le quartier de
chefski où la station métro de la a été
endommagé ce n'est pas la première fois
les habitants sont sous le
choc vous voyez ça c'est la réponse au
politiciens ville loin de la ligne de
front sans combat est-ce qu'il devrait
aider l'Ukraine ou non il faudrait qu'il
vienne ici et qu'il constate ce qui est
fait à l'Ukraine tous les jours et àif
KERS
zapor on é en route pour le jardin
d'enfants par que c'est là qu'on se
réfugie habituellement et l'explosion a
eu lieu heureusement nous n'y étions pas
parce que c'était un tel chaos dans le
quartier il y avait tell de méro c'est
juste terrible je suis le
choc au moment de l'explosion beaucoup
de gens étai dans le métro sur
l'escalator je ne sais pas où ils sont
passés peut-être que les employés du
métro ne les ont pas laissé sortir et
tous ces gens dans la rue regardez tous
les fragments ils auraient pu toucher
quelqu'un alors que les secouristent de
fouiller les décombres ici à keV comme
ailleur dans le pays le lourd bilan
matériel et humainre fois que les civils
sont les premières victimes de
l'agression russe contre l'Ukraine